he had a relationship with the BTK
killer or something like that what yeah
crazy Burger the king killer the BTK guy
you remember the burger the King
which I like making the stallion kind of
yeah I don't know dude murder the King
Burger
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah so uh who is up to speed on this
Idaho case oh dude I gave up on it why
because it's so sad it's super sad yeah
you don't know anything about it okay
Tiff has been watching it she's been
following you gotta speak as if somebody
doesn't know anything about it before we
talk about it though every time Tiff
watches a video on this Idaho killer
they're always like we
we need more news we we can't release
any more details it's all like
trying to figure out what happened and
they can't give you any answers so every
bit but they're milking this murder for
everything they got because it's such a
crazy story but every time they talk
about it they're like we can't release
any more details we have no idea and
every time they do that speculation ends
up hurting some innocent other person
that had nothing to do with it and so
the story is some some PhD student
studying criminology from Scranton
Pennsylvania right he drove all the way
to Idaho
killed four college students three girls
one guy one person was like murdered
more than the other I guess they were
like he was trying to send a message to
one of them apparently can we put a
Chiron under under him real quick I wish
the news was delivered by this man and
it was so good I think uh sort of this
happens and like this guy like um yeah
so he like drives he's a Pisces they
keep talking about the Hyundai Elantra
dude they keep talking about the Hyundai
Elantra the Hyundai Elantra is a really
big part of this case they keep saying
that maybe a sponsor like that's the new
way of sponsoring these kind of things
that's the brand deal of today Brandon
immigration because I just watched uh
Viva Las Vegas
um the Elvis movie and I realized that
those movies are just tourism
sponsorships
it was called Viva loss I thought I just
called the elements I thought it was
cool though yeah boss lemon's Elvis Joe
watched the porn called people
[Laughter]
as Elvis the old Mall
okay okay because he has another one
with Hawaii right yeah that's what I was
like because I watched those as a kid
and I re-watched them now with an adult
mine I'm like
this is this is all a tourism marketing
campaign oh yeah because they're like
these are the things you can they're
like going on dates look you could see
the Hoover Dam and then it's like it's
all a [ __ ] advertisement and I'm like
see this is the new style is like
they're sponsoring these videos these
[ __ ] murderers yeah and then the news
is like brought to you by the new Honda
Elantra can I ask right away with murder
okay can I ask how Elvis sold people
looking at the Hoover Dam
they were on a date on a helicopter and
then um his girl was was educating him
on all like you could be you could jet
you could water ski there you're gonna
say no more and then they went down on
their helicopter and they started jet
skiing at the Hoover Dam at the Hoover
damage I didn't know you could do that
yeah and then they're like talking about
yeah you could rent boats here you could
do this and then it's actually kind of
lit yeah I didn't know that do you know
the details well enough to recap I just
dude I gave a sick recap right now
because it is this is like the most
interesting [ __ ] online right it is can
you over the [ __ ] Mexican El Chapo oh
that is crazy
I think more people care about this
honestly yeah how sad it is okay
is kind of expected that which we'll
talk about later guys at a time one at a
time let's finish your thing though so
that people can be up to speed yeah
Anthony's gonna do it go ahead no go
back because I forgot for me I was
thinking about the state of our economy
but go ahead well it's just a
criminology PhD student killed four
people he drove to Idaho Moscow Idaho
right keep repeating the same things
Nick come on he killed three girls and a
guy and then he went back to he he just
said there's no more details after that
that is a criminology major that's
everything up to this point and
apparently like he uh he had a
relationship with the BTK killer or
something like that what yeah crazy
Burger the king killer the BTK guy you
don't remember the burger the king
the BTK killer is the guy it's not like
Megan D stallion kind of yeah I don't
know dude Burger the King Burger thing
stupid dude you're so stupid it's a
[ __ ] K-pop dude it was [ __ ] you're
dumb the B2K killer was [ __ ] wild bro
BTK is a K-Pop group dude I take my
shout out back by the way though that
was good marketing that was good
marketing by Burger King though yeah
burger the king it really was
a [ __ ] idiot
damn it okay the man accused emerging
for the University of Idaho students in
November had thoroughly cleaned the
interior and exterior of his car and was
also seen wearing surgical gloves
multiple times before being apprehended
the Hyundai Elantra so I'm guessing with
the Honda Elantra the reason why they're
so fixated on it is because of the way
he meticulously was trying to clean and
or cover it up but I think there was
just kind of a meticulous nature about
him in general which uh some uh well
that's his [ __ ] major right
criminology
he was a yeah he was pursuing a PhD in
criminal justice at Washington State
University at the time of the killings
uh they said again he cleaned his car
inside and out not missing an inch
according to the law enforcement Source
um The Source who spoke on the condition
of anonymity was briefed on observations
made by investigators during four days
of surveillance leading up to
co-burger's arrest his name coburger
coburger at his family's Pennsylvania
home on December 30th
as coburger now remains behind bars in
Idaho waiting his January 12th status
hearing new details have emerged
elucidate elucidating some of the
suspects movements in the days leading
up to his arrest
um Burger the King was found co-burger
the king
[Music]
what do you guys are saying
the victim's father says the suspect was
hunting them so uh one so he went to
school and then he he wanted to test his
work kind of thing right like he was
trying to see if he could get away with
it [ __ ] maybe I could also assume it
might be like way more you know just
dark where it's like you know you become
like a criminology major so you can
learn how to like cover stuff you know
what I mean you're like researching it's
like when they're talking about isn't
[ __ ] Dahmer and stuff when he got
into Taxidermy but really it was like a
training grounds for human beings you
know what I'm saying but I think that's
what the big story is and why people are
so fascinated with this is because they
want to know what the motive is yeah
because they don't they still don't know
right yeah they well they haven't really
talked about it and I think you know so
much of this is still in like under they
haven't found any personal connection at
all well I think they just can't release
it because once they release it in the
Press I'm sure it probably makes it
harder is that the victim's dad this guy
Steve gun called this because we're in a
[ __ ] hex hat
that's a crypto that's a tragic crypto
yeah
that's the craziest thing get out of
here get out of here
stinky he said nobody understands
exactly uh why but he was stalking them
he was hunting them he was a person
looking for an opportunity and it just
happened to be at that house and that's
hard to take this is the one it's so far
away from him though how did he like he
drove all the way over there I think
they're gonna try him back in Idaho too
apparently yeah he said he said she had
her phone right next to her and she
couldn't call 9-1-1 so these were just
girls that went to sleep that night and
it cowered you know a hunter that went
out and he picked his little opponent
that was girls that's probably why the
house was targeted none of these girls
deserve this the real problem we have is
that we have an individual that thought
it was okay to attack other human beings
that's what I'm going to focus on he
said I'd be a little bit surprised if
there wasn't a clearer touch point that
would suggest that he was interested in
one or two of the people more than he
was the others why do they always choose
girls
easy prank maybe yeah probably yeah if
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you want to
attack something that can't fight you as
hard
or you should fight the chicks who think
that they're equally strong
[Laughter]
though that's a worthy opponent at least
at least they learned something from it
and they'll probably fight back hard too
because they got something to prove yeah
it says still The public's view of the
case remains mired with questions as of
late Thursday it remains unclear what
motivated the killings it's also unclear
how the suspect entered the house after
authorities said there was no sign of
forced entry or why two roommates were
inside the Residence at the time of the
killings survived the attacks so two
other residents oh two people survived
oh survived or they weren't even
attacked at all they were in maybe they
weren't attacked uh at all but they were
in the building is all I mean what is it
oh it's in your mind I want to know
there were people who were raised to
well they believed they were raised to
to know that they're not as strong as
men because they were told they're on
the strongest man
so they never push themselves so there
are no there are people yeah that's what
I'm saying and then they get shocked
when they're not as strong as guys and
then they're like
[Laughter]
anyways
anyways
they probably just didn't lock their
door man because you you don't you know
like it's a nice neighborhood we live in
Idaho it's all nice and cheap like when
you're in college living with a bunch of
people we didn't lock our door either
dude I lock my door everywhere I go oh
and only because I I grew up with such a
big family that you had no privacy at
any point so anytime I go to the
bathroom Nikki always makes fun of me
because she's like what do you think I'm
gonna go to the bathroom after you and
I'm like I just do it instinctually I
just like I [ __ ] immediately so
here's here's how investigators uh
narrowed the search to coburger
um DNA trash recovered from coburger's
family home revealed that the DNA
profile obtained from the trash was
linked to DNA on a tan leather knife
sheath found laying on the bed of one of
the victims wow according to a probable
cause affidavit released Thursday the
DNA recovered from the trash is believed
to be that of the biological father of
the person whose DNA was found on the
sheet
two phone records authorities found the
suspect's phone was near the victim's
Moscow Idaho home at least a dozen times
between June 2022 to the present day
according to the affidavit the records
also revealed coburger's phone was near
the crime scene hours after the murders
that morning between 9 12 a.m and 9 21
a.m
the killings were not reported to
authorities until just before noon how
long do you think he's been planning
because I'm wondering if he even chose
this degree because he was like I want
to figure out how people look for
Killers well he wouldn't have left the
sheath if he was that meticulous what
was that yeah that's yeah and then
here's the third point the white sedan
the Hyundai Elantra Elantra was seen
near the victim's home around the time
of their killings officers of Washington
State University identified a white
Elantra and later learned it was
registered to co-burger the same car was
also found at the suspect's Pennsylvania
family home when he was arrested that uh
last night that'd be funny if it starts
to really sound like a brand deal
whether like the same awesome car was
found
his MPG was known to be highly
reasonable the same Fork door with
heated seats
all the features man I'm not even
talking about the physical with great
APR this year with a reasonable MSRP
wonderful defrost mode yeah only three
left at the dealership all terrain tires
but it's so funny like because I was
making fun of Tiff for watching all
these videos and I was like saying like
babe they haven't found anything yet
like stop watching these videos and
every video she's watching they always
talk about the [ __ ] about it yeah yeah
because it's like the most mysterious
yeah I wonder if the sales are actually
going up I'm sure it might have been a
Brand recognition dude the Ford Bronco
yeah for real that's why it's forever
legendary ever OJ Bronco baby that was
the subjects too it's like if you're
gonna get away
need need to get away
Bronco it's a sweet ride to get away
from the cops
[Music]